I want to talk a little bit about
foreign policy now that during a town
hall event in New Hampshire recently
Republican presidential candidate Donald
Trump uh express contempt to put it
lightly for Hillary Clinton's plan to
fight terrorists groups like Isis now of
course most of Donald Trump's comments
about Hillary Clinton and Isis have been
just fabricated lies like for example
that Hillary Clinton has been fighting
Isis her entire adult life Trump has
been criticized for not publicly
discussing the details of how would you
fight terror how would you defeat Isis
etcetera he had the bright idea at this
event in New Hampshire to say hey what
about attacking first for once I guess
reminiscing about the good old days of
pre-emptive war I guess pre-emptive Wars
like the one he claim to oppose in Iraq
but actually said he'd be in favor of on
the Howard Stern Show I know I can't
figure it out any more easily than you
can here's audio and video of Trump
saying what if we struck first once
isn't there an element of surprise
remember when we were young and we're
studying history and to talk about some
of the great generals in the great
attacks it was called the element of
surprise would it be nice if we attacked
first and talked about our great victory
later ya know you know seriously who's
gonna I like how the audience burst out
laughing like yeah that's funny yeah oh
he's serious all well now I'm going to
clap hopefully a few people in that room
considering crying because that's really
the reaction I should be having question
one is attack who first right i mean
i'll tell you uh if if I were Trump I
guess I would say the people who would
be attacked they know who they are and
they've been killing us for a long time
but let me just say they wouldn't see it
coming that much I can tell you trust me
that's the Trump explanation for who we
attack first and one of the biggest
things that Trump supporters were going
after Hillary Clinton over uh about over
the last few weeks has been look at all
the wars Hillary Clinton will start
there's one candidate now reminiscing
about how nice it would be to attack
somebody first it's not hill
Clinton Pat its Donald Trump how is this
not obvious to the Trump stirs the
trumpeters who say Hillary is going to
get us into a ton of wars but it's your
candidate who's glorifying pre-emptive
strikes and you remember to I mean not
long ago 10 years ago we did attack a
country first yeah Rach and it didn't
end up so well now I mean cost us
trillions 4,000 of our own troops dead
and yeah up to a million Iraqis so and
that was a war that he supported well
yeah I mean of course now he'll say he
didn't support it but there's multiple
interviews where he did seem in favor of
it bottom line he just didn't have any
clue about anything and said whatever
came to mind at the time and there's a
trend in this with Trump Trump suggested
that it would be an okay an acceptable
and reasonable thing for more countries
to have nuclear weapons Donald Trump
Express confusion as to why nuking
Europe would be so crazy and should be
off the table tempest Trump is talked
multiple times about pre-emptive war and
of course there was that horrifying
incident from Morning Joe on MSNBC where
it was reported that in a meeting a
one-hour meeting three times Trump was
confused about we why we couldn't just
nuke other countries and why it would be
such a big deal so up very very
disturbing gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com / TDPS